[Music]
who was planning the the excursions that
you would take when you had some time
off really we must kind of did it like
should go on a boat yeah Katie was
swimming out and I started to impress
her but she's like a mermaid like just
see like Kate Hudson's but like
snorkeling in front of you and then yes
Li I know I don't I know that it's not
what I look my great like she comes in
she's like like both of that we have
paparazzi and they just I mean couldn't
ugh love tomorrow these two get along so
well you think they were really related
seriously Amy even looks as if she could
be Kate's sister and just listen to
Goldie play the proud mama
so it was my knee and my two daughters
hmm hard to believe they've only been
friends since production began on their
new movie snatched they get some major
bonding on the set playing what else
a mother-daughter duo who's South
American vacation goes horribly wrong
when they are kidnapped we will get out
of here you get there okay it's called
ease first comedy and 14 years her last
one was the banker sisters co-starring
with her pal Susan Sarandon
and none of it would have happened
without a bold move from Amy I just
approached her on a plane and I want you
to be in a movie makes you think okay oh
and you said 14 years you went 14 years
this is the one I mean this is clearly
the right one to come back into I also
haven't worked in 14 years but not by
choice
there came a period Radtke am I done is
it maybe is it time to go back I don't
know I was sort of doing this in and
then I met Amy really that's what
happened
we had like unbelievable sure against
smart as a whip perfect ass oh I'll go
where Oh
[Music]
you